In 2011, a Pixar employee named Emma
Coats wrote a Twitter thread on the 22
rules for storytelling. They're an
absolute masterclass in story,
psychology, and human persuasion. And in
today's video, I'm going to show you
exactly how I use these storytelling
secrets to write highly addictive emails
to over 4,000 copywriters every single
day that tell me personally, I can't
stop reading these. They are so
good. So, if you're interested in
stealing the secrets from the world's
greatest storytellers so you can become
a better writer and even sell more of
your own products, then this is going to
be the best video that you watch all
day. But just a heads up, I'm going to
put all 22 Pixar storytelling rules down
in the description below, but I'm only
going to be breaking down the 13 rules
that I've personally used to make my
writing more addictive and generate over
six figures of income in my copywriting
business every year. Starting with rule
number one. Rule number one is you
admire a character for trying more than
their successes. In this context, in my
business, I am my own character. I write
personal brand emails coming from me to
my customers and readers offering
products that I sell on my own. You are
your own character in your brand.
Whether you have a a YouTube channel, a
Twitter following, an email-based
business like mine. The idea is that
hopefully you are a character that your
readers like. You want your readers to
like you and they want you to succeed,
but they don't want you to succeed
easily. People don't like it when
somebody is just constantly winning and
winning and winning and winning and it's
no fun to read. So, you have to sprinkle
in the hard roads, the detours, the
things that have been thrown your way
that have tried to stop you from
success. This is the opposite of what
most gurus try and teach you to be an
authority and you're always posting your
wins, wins, wins. But people want to see
the humanity in your storytelling. You
have to overcome obstacles and it makes
your storytelling far more addictive
because people don't know whether you're
going to get there or not. And it also
creates this underdog tone because they
want to continue to cheer for you. In
essence, no great story has ever been
told about a character who did
everything right.
Rule number two, you have to keep in
mind what's interesting to you as an
audience, not what's fun to you as a
writer. They often can be very
different. The sweet spot in your
writing and storytelling needs to be in
the middle of what do you want to write
and what do your readers want to read?
What is interesting to them? This is
copywriting 101 is that you are focused
on your reader's journey. They see
themselves in your journey, but you have
to write the things they want to read.
So before I ever even put pen to paper
on my typewriter or anything like that,
I'm always thinking, is this going to be
interested to my readers? Is this what
they like? And a lot of times I'll even
point it back to data. I go back to
emails I've written before that I've
gotten a lot of replies, a lot of
purchases on my products and things like
that. Or if you've written threads, what
have they liked before? And that kind of
gives you an inclination of what your
readers enjoy and what they don't enjoy.
And spend more time writing the stories
that they enjoy. Rule number six, what
is your character comfortable with, good
at? Throw the opposite at them.
Challenge them. make them respond. So in
this essence, if you are the character,
what is the thing that you're really,
really good at? Try something else in
life to create stories that increase the
amount of obstacles for you. I know this
sounds counterintuitive. You want to
continue to win, but remember, rule
number one is people don't want to read
people who are just always succeeding
and everything goes right for them. For
example, I'm a clientless copywriter. I
don't write for clients almost ever. I
write my own stuff and build my own
products, but every once in a while, I
will take on a client in a niche that
I've never written for ever before just
for the story to see how it goes.
Sometimes it goes crazy and I get a
viral story like the one I wrote on
Twitter one time where I fired a $6,000
client. Sometimes it goes really, really
well and I still get the story. Do
things in your life that make you, the
character, get out of your comfort zone
so you can at least get a story out of
it. Rule number seven, come up with an
ending before you figure out the middle.
Endings are hard. The way that I use
this in my email storytelling is I
always get in front of my readers of
what I am trying to accomplish next.
Whether it's launching a new business or
even things like a personal hobby,
breaking 100 in my golf game, there's
always some goal, some ending that I am
chasing after and I'm kind of guiding my
reader along in the journey so they know
what exactly it is that I'm chasing. It
gives them clarity. It gives them a map.
And you don't always have to give away
the ending, but at least knowing your
end goal will give you a map of what to
write towards. Rule number eight, finish
your story even if it's not perfect. In
an ideal world, you have both, but move
on and do better next time. This is a
rule I apply every single day because,
as you know, I write a daily email to my
4,000 plus copywriters and readers. And
people often ask me like, how do you
write a daily email? Like there just the
perfectionist in them or the idea of
coming up with stories is that not every
single thing that you write is going to
be gold. But the more you write, the
more chances that your writing is going
to be better and better and better and
better. I've personally put myself on
the hook that every day I'm going to
tell one story to my audience. I'm going
to try and make it as amazing as
possible. But some days it's just it is
what it is. You ship it. You move on.
This is the best way to become an
incredible storyteller is that you show
up every day. You write a story. You
write your email. You write your thread.
Whatever it is, you ship it. You move
on. and you do better tomorrow. Rule
number 10, pull apart the stories you
like. What you like in them is part of
you. You've got to recognize it before
you could use it. This is something that
I recommend every copywriter writer has
is a swipe file. Every time I read
something that's incredibly interesting,
especially a story or anything like
that, I put it in my digital swipe file.
I keep a notion folder with all of the
great stories. I copy and paste them in.
I move them along and I try and figure
out what is it that I like about this
story, specifically things that made me
buy something. If your story, your email
made me buy something, I try and reverse
psychology that and say, "What emotions
did you trigger that made me so enticed
that I actually spent money on this
thing?" And I use that in my copywriting
tactics. Understanding what makes you
tick as as the audience will help put
your brain in the audience's shoes when
you are writing for them. Rule number
11, putting it on paper lets you start
fixing it. If it stays in your head,
you'll never share it with anyone. One
of the best pieces of wisdom that I've
ever gotten from my mentors and other
writers is that writing begets writing.
Meaning, you're not writing once you get
the idea. You're writing to get the
idea. Sometimes I've had just a crinkle
of a thought that I said, hm, what is
that? And then you start writing it.
Just a draft. Nobody has to see it. And
you let the idea come to you. You let
the story evolve on its own as you are
writing. Often times when I write my
500, 600, 700word emails, I barely have
a sentence that's like, I think this is
the direction I want to go in and I just
keep going and let it flow out. And
often times I ship those stories with
very little editing because I figured
out that the way that it's evolved on
its own is really, really natural. So
don't worry about perfecting the idea
before you start writing it out. Write
it out to get the idea. Rule number 13
is give your characters opinions.
Passive malleable might seem likable as
you write, but it's poison to your
audience. This specific rule reminds me
of that part in in Revelation in the
Bible where it talks about like God will
spit out the lukewarm. The same thing is
true with your audience in your reading.
When you write lukewarm, when you're not
for or against anything, your writing
becomes really boring. It's not really
interesting at all. People want to know
what exactly is your character for? What
is the things that they love? What are
they passionate about? What are they
striving for? And what is your character
against? What are the things that they
hate? What do they find evil in the
world? You have to have those two things
in your branding. You have to have a
brand enemy and a brand ally in your
writing. And oftentimes, it's best to
have one of each that you beat up over
time. Think Harry Potter Voldemort type
thing. He has a huge enemy that it took
seven books to defeat. People don't get
sick of your enemy. They continue to
rally around your enemy. This is going
to create super fans for your brand. And
it's also going to repel the people who
honestly you want nothing to do with
your reading. You don't want them
reading your stuff anyway. Rule number
14. Why must you tell this story? What
is the burning belief in you that your
story feeds off of? Whenever you sit
down to tell a story, you have to go
back to the heart of it and say, "Why
did I think this was good anyway? What
made me think, man, that would be super
fun to tell?" The heart of the story is
often the same emotion you're actually
trying to emulate in your reader. Did it
make you happy? Did it make you sad? Did
it make you angry? That's what makes a
good story is the heart of it gave you
some sort of emotion and you're trying
to replicate that emotion in the person
reading it. So that's going to guide the
way that you write your stories because
you're going to use certain verbiage to
evoke certain emotions. And that emotion
originally started with you. Rule number
15. If you were your character in this
situation, how would you feel? Honesty
lends credibility, which if you're a
copywriter like me, credibility is the
number one resource to salesmanship.
Because people are not buying your
product, they're buying you. especially
in a business like mine where it's a
personal branded business, not a a logo
or anything like that. Some of the best
emails that I've ever written that
people have replied and buyed from are
when I genuinely just wore my heart on
my sleeve. I've told stories where I've
been angry at clients where clients have
shafted me in the past and how pissed
off they made me and I was just really
honest. And I've told heartfelt stories
where I was struggling with my business
and I was just thinking about past times
and really heartfelt stories and I've
been really really honest about it and
those have built the most trust where
people are like, "Oh, he's not just some
fake guru trying to, you know, sell his
own stuff. This this guy's a real human
with a family, with emotions, with life,
with problems, with wins, with
successes." And and I can relate to
that. And so people tend to believe you
more because you're being honest. You're
not coding the Instagram highlight reel
of I'm always winning. And vulnerability
is so rare nowadays that when you inject
it into your storytelling, it makes
people really believe that this is worth
reading. Rule number 16, what are the
stakes? Give us a reason to root for the
character. What happens if they don't
succeed? Stack the odds against them.
Stakes is one of the most underrated
forms of storytelling. I like to combine
this with uh finishing the ending of
your story. What is the thing that
you're trying to reach as a character?
So, you have the ending in mind in that
earlier rule. Let's say you as a
personal brand are writing a story about
how you're going to build a million-doll
agency, for example, right? You are the
character in that story. The ending is
that you've achieved a million-doll
agency. What are the stakes if you do
not achieve that agency? You have to
make the stakes detrimental not just to
yourself, but to your reader. And that
increases the chances that people are
genuinely rooting for you to continue
winning. They want you to achieve your
goals. So you start building this super
fan base of people who see your goal and
they see all the odds stacked against
you. All the things you can't overcome.
You have to learn this. You don't have
time. You have a family depending on
you. All of these sorts of things create
stakes that if you don't achieve this
goal, this bad thing happens. Rule
number 17, no work is ever wasted. If
it's not working, let go and move on.
It'll come back around to be useful for
later. I cannot tell you how many times
I've started writing a story, an email,
a thread, or whatever, and I just like,
man, I'm just not feeling it. This is
not It's not great. It's not hitting me.
I I don't think I have it. This is this
is not right. It's not wasted because
I'll leave that document. I'll walk away
for a couple hours. I'll go play a round
of golf. I'll go hang out with my kids.
I'll go read a book. I'll go work on
something else. I will come back a
couple days later, a week later, two
weeks later, whatever it is. I'll come
back and tip tap that story and it will
bam, it will click. For whatever reason,
I have reused and used stories that I
thought were dead and brought them back
to life. So, do not be discouraged if
you start writing something and it
doesn't click. Just have a place where
you can come back to that story, some
kind of indraft folder. Again, I like to
use notion and I just set it up in a
canban like haven't started, currently
writing, published. I do those three and
I have so many things in my currently
writing and I cannot tell you how many
times I'll just go click through and I'm
like, "What is this story?" Oh yeah. And
I'll come back there and I'll rewrite
it. Give yourself an opportunity to
finish it later. You don't have to knock
it out today. And the last rule that
we're going to touch is rule number 22.
What is the essence of your story? And
what's the most economical way of
telling it? If you know that, you can
build it out from there. The essence of
your story is what we call in
copywriting your big idea. Your story
should have one big idea, one main thing
that you're trying to get across, one
plot, one guidance towards the end
result. Especially when you're writing
short stories like myself, I'm writing
500 to 600word style emails. I'm not
writing a 500page novel, right? We're
writing Twitter threads. We're writing
emails. We're writing ads. We're writing
things like that. And so we're using
these stories in the most economical way
possible. What's the beginning? What's
the middle? What's the end? And what's
the one thing that I'm trying to get
across? Most people make the mistake of
interweaving too many concepts, too many
characters, too many stories, too many
plot lines within the story and and to
try and condense that in 500 words is so
confusing to the reader. They just don't
understand what is the point of this.
the fewer the characters, the fewer the
plot lines, the fewer the angles, things
like that, start there. Get it to its
bare essence. And if you can, and you're
an advanced enough writer and you can
add some twist, add some turns without
actually diluting the story itself, then
do that. But start as simple and basic
as possible. That's it. Those are the 13
out of the 22 Pixar storytelling secrets
that I think are going to help you to
become a highly addictive writer. and
sell more of your stuff to grow your
business and really get your writing out
there. If you enjoyed these tips, then
you are definitely going to love my free
copywriting guide called Copywriting
Catalyst. It actually carries 63 more
tips on how to be highly persuasive with
your writing to sell more of your stuff
with writing. I'm going to leave a link
to that in the description below. All
you got to do is click it, put your
email in, and it'll send to you
instantly.
[Music]